with more than half of the afghan
population suffering from what the un
calls extreme levels of hunger the
secretary general antonio gutierrez
again sounded the alarm
six months after the takeover by the
taliban afghanistan is hanging by a
threat
for afghans daily life has become a
frozen hell
one of afghanistan's best known women's
rights campaigners who still lives in
kabul came to new york to address the
security council
after 20 years of tasting freedom
working studying playing sports
performing music it has taken less than
six months
to completely dismantle the rights of
the women and girls across the country
her account was backed by the un's
special representative inside
afghanistan deborah lyons said a number
of women activists had recently been
abducted and then had disappeared she
said this was part of a wider deeply
worrying pattern and here on the ground
there is compelling evidence of an
emerging environment of intimidation
and a deterioration
in respect for human rights
this suggests that the consolidation of
government authority
may be leading toward control of the
population by fear
rather than by understanding and
responding to its needs the meeting was
presided over by norway's prime minister
jonas gastore his government flew a
taliban delegation for talks in oslo
with international diplomats in afghan
civil society in recent days
in an interview for talk to al jazeera
he told me this was not meant to give
the group legitimacy or recognition to
me it looks like this if we don't sit
down with them
present the expectation the demands and
what they have to deliver
afghanistan is going to sink down in a
tremendous humanitarian disaster most of
afghanistan's reserves remain frozen but
the un wants to change that without
renewed liquidity in the afghan economy
there's a risk the dire humanitarian
situation becomes a country-wide famine
on the other hand some nations still
worry about rewarding the taliban when
the human rights situation in particular
the treatment of women seems to be
getting worse not better james bayes al
jazeera at the united nations